tu vas devoir tuer une petite flopée de
méchant qui mérite complètement de
mourir parce que c'est ton destin
il faut que tu retrouves ceux qui ont
fait ça
et que tu le rend la pareille
il faut que tu la mettes cette cravate
ça fait négliger sans être
on a compris tel tueur cas pas envie de
tuer c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
c'est grâce à ce singe que j'ai survécu
comment tu sais qu'il n'était pas là
pour tuer tes qu'un tour
il fait partie des gentils ton truc à
toi savane de tuer les tueurs
[Applaudissements]
pas vraiment envie de te battre avec une
main attachée dans le dos
je sais que tu peux utiliser tes pieds
c'était une image
[Musique]
il vient pour nous protéger tous
ça va saigner
deux bus deux destins
et une virée inoubliable